hello everybody what is up pressure here
and I'm joined by ammunition oh my gosh
I'm actually really excited today we are
sponsored by PlayStation now and we're
gonna be playing unchartered four
sponsored by PlayStation now and if you
didn't know PlayStation now lets you
stream more than 800 PlayStation games
on your ps4 or your PC plus you can also
download any of the 300 plus ps4 games
in the service directly to your ps4 you
can learn more now at PSN now calm and
we'll give you more details on that
later but for now let's jump on into the
game into the action and first of all
thank you all so much for joining us and
thank you and for being here we were
talking a little bit before about you
know the series and everything and
you're a huge fan so I'm excited I see
uncharted for him the thing and I was
just like it whatever it is I'm in yeah
and not only is unchartered 4
unchartered I keep seeing Uncharted it's
uncharted Uncharted um all of the
Uncharted games are on there pretty much
which is another really cool feature so
if you like this one or you're just
playing this one for the first time you
can go back and play the other ones too
which I highly recommend because this is
probably my favorite single-player
series of games
Nighy ever so and to have all of them at
your fingertips it's pretty good pretty
convenient we're actually starting kind
of in the beginning of the game right
now let's just get away from
turning this down a little bit but yeah
still towards the beginning got through
like the super tutorial II part of it at
least but now we're on the run
we're break another prison break it out
brother wait up Sam doing real brotherly
thing I remember to climb climb Nathan
there's no time you're being riddled
with bullets right now I love these
games the animation is so good like the
animation of the movements and
everything and how they interact with
the walls and things that are are next
to them the fact that they actually like
grab the where we going what you doing
Sam like you notice when he's like
running by the walls and stuff he
actually like puts his hand on it to
raise himself and stuff instead of just
like kind of scraping along like most
care ok yes oh oh and now I'm being shot
thanks dude yeah it's all his fault
ain't gonna be good climb faster when
your vision starts to go black and white
that's when you know you've been shot by
too many bullets Nathan
of course of course always this happens
about 75 times this game you know what
down the bro definitely came back down
to help water brothers for
Oh assistance required nope never mind I
got it okay
layin em I'll get soaked oh yeah oh the
haymaker this looks like a thing we can
inter
Sully's in this gaming write the volume
good for you let me turn up a little bit
uh it's more quiet for me oh that way
okay feel and hear the intenseness I
mean I personally have never escaped
from jail but I imagine it would be
pretty we are escaping from the prison
yeah this is like oh god I don't know if
I was supposed to jump over okay we're
jumping this is the various is like the
second yeah very early on the guy who
voiced Nolan North actually voiced
doesn't miles he does a lot of these
climbing games like oh man I would never
[Music]
leave my Nate your brother is dead
either come home join him how you grieve
alright man need some time to process
this I wouldn't just went I love these
games now it's like his voice is so much
louder because like his voice in his
head processing all these emotions
yeah the echo effects get you
[Music]
we were just sliding around
[Music]
yes yeah so like we said we're still
pretty early on but definitely already
juicy it right out of the gate
Sam I don't think appeared in any of the
other training it's been a long time
since I think no more than just like
references this is maybe the first one
it was like actually
my characters they do a lot of like
we're not gonna get
[Music]
there's definitely some sections where
it's like
they're like childhood so it's like
Nathan and Sam it's like kids and it
shows you a lot about how they grow and
stuff which is really cool
and those are like also some really fun
because it's not just like sometimes
would be you eating soup like you as a
child seeds it's like you can actually
do very much yeah no but they actually
have like a lot of like climbing and
yeah I like that they kind of
incorporated that into like the learning
phase of the game in the beginning like
oh this is how you climb this is how you
do stuff but this is also very important
to the story
[Music]
but that one came after
[Music]
you wouldn't like put your mic like
directly to your face okay yeah it's
pretty direct on just so everyone can
hear your voice 15 years that's a long
time remember when I play this the first
time like we had all that prison see you
know just like 15 years like well what
happened to the beat time and I guess
it's like all the other games happen
look so good okay I'm gonna do something
really quick yeah go Brandon on the the
subtitles
oh I usually like to have I don't know
what that would be audio accessibility
maybe yeah the bottom one thank you
sweet
yeah naughty dog makes places you I
don't know if they are they owned by
Sony Computer Entertainment maybe but
they made also the Last of Us and I saw
something shiny can I have that all the
shiny things there honestly just like
one of the best game devs I think they
do just such a quality job and then Last
of Us part 2 is on the way
here we go
so yeah you guys this game did come out
in 2016 but that's probably one of my
favorite things about PS now is that
they have a lot of you know classics and
favorites and even if they are a few
years old they're still just like worth
playing no matter when you learn about
it even if it's your first time or it's
been a while and then they have the
other ones in the series too like if
this is your first time playing I'm
trying to for and you like it go back
and play the whole series why no it's
there that's a cool thing about PS now
I've been doing the same thing with like
God of War in the series it's good it's
good
highly recommend and if you think about
it like one year subscription is like 60
bucks and that's like the price of one
game nowadays oh yeah that's true
so you're actually getting a you know a
lot for your money in this subscription
[Music]
yeah I think we're playing our regular
PlayStation 4 sometimes people want to
know if it's guesswork oh yeah this is a
regular ps4 actually this is a pro I
recently got it switched out and don't
forget you can also download the PS now
app on your PC and play all these games
on your PC which is really cool oh snap
the tech okay everything's going to well
oh he said Axl's okay on the other side
then yep got it just a little bit of a
stormwater maneuver here is that other
words yeah there's oxygen in the water
okay we're fine
that's 200 right cuz there's one under
the box or under the trailer I forgot
about that one you know a rogue box down
here we gotta collect this one we have
to smash X to lift the box
PlayStation now only available in the US
it should be available everywhere that
you play your PlayStation that's
actually a good question not a question
I've received yet but my assumption
would be it's available everywhere
because I mean it would be really
unfortunate if it was only yes I highly
doubt that that's the case
you know it's for everyone it's for all
the PlayStation lovers out there
the other cool thing is that there are
some multiplayer games that you can play
on PS now like Grand Theft Auto and
stuff and you can play those online
without a Playstation like PS Plus like
if you subscribe to PS now your online
capabilities through PS now will be
enough for you to play online that's
also another convenient addition
agreed
this is the post they actually said that
I read that they actually tried to face
his appearance off of a combo of or his
personality off of Johnny Knoxville and
then his appearance off of like Harrison
Ford which makes sense cuz it's like
kind of Indiana Jones yes interesting
Johnny Knoxville huh a little bit less
crazy yeah it's good to be back toss
down your gear here you go Thanks my
knees hurt watching I know that was an
intense drop I'm just making your job
easier right I'm stunned no you know
it's stunning you smell general left it
reminds me of your mom
[Music]
I know you some old man come back
straightening out it still looks so good
come on hey so how about you let someone
else be point man next time
you've earned a break oh no thanks take
a dive over being at the office anything
yeah either way it's gonna be a while to
the next day you're talking about but
there's this job oh come on
no you gotta be kidding me
dang someone's willing to go on those
dives for the low-low money we get care
to do the honors sure yeah sure bar
thank you Thanks
[Laughter]
just melt it down make some petty come
on let's go celebrate first rounds on me
with you guys as 'red pay it's all the
same to you I think I'm just gonna do
the paperwork and get home and crash
rain check though alright I'm gonna lie
that's a mood right there give my money
and go home sleep I love how they set it
up to make it seem like Oh something
cool like yeah like we picked up these
boxes from the bottom of the river you
know it's got to be awesome and there's
just like spools of copper here like
yeah kind of like sitting up in that old
man life now got some news from
eye-contact about that wreck off the
coast of Malaysia the ships intact yeah
cargos right for the picking
you are persistent when I'll give you
that hey and all the money came through
for the equipment too we are all set
except uh my best guy god I trust with a
job the only one he he's got cold feet
my feet were never warm to begin with
and tell me this contact yours you get
the permits no he did not get the
permits can't no one get the damn
permission Nate don't you see that works
in our favor no permits means no
competition the ship it's ours
no permits means no go Nate this is
retirement money for the both of us okay
I don't know about you but I don't want
to be work as Salvage
xD do you sure beats prison oh yeah he
pulled that from the heart better than
being in jail so say hi to Carl and the
kids for me right no pressure Nate but
think about it
really did your homework on this one
they put so much detail into this stuff
down the search area would make a hell
of a fine no no way you are going with
the others cats like what could go wrong
hmm
this is like his attic and so you can
see kind of a lot of Easter eggs for
from the other game that's cool this is
basically where he's just shoved all the
treasures and things that he's
collecting they're definitely doing a
good job and making it feel like all
this stuff is a past-life type thing for
him
you got that one guy hey come on back
collected along the years like if you
played the other games and it's just
like oh that's awesome
Spanish doubloon found in a German
u-boat in the middle of a jungle
and he says just enough about it to kind
of make you wonder maybe I should go
check that out
yeah yeah that's cool no
what else we got
yeah sure yeah the puzzles in this game
are so cool there's so much stuff yeah
so say there's a lot each other for a
piece of this yeah oh wait we can shake
it oh no I can't pick it up and down
I can't interact with it again after
I've already put it down oh that's that
I'm so sad it said shake and I
I know it glows but that's the best part
come on Chad really my style any more
ruins we have to start over now let's
start the stream from the beginning
intro and everything Chloe
so Chloe's actually the time Chloe she's
the main character that they focus on in
lost legacy which is the one that they
made after this one
I think the ammo in the bottom left even
bullseye take that so many eat plastic
business sorry I'm handling important
important business I'm just keeping a
safe I wish you could take the toy gun
down with you like all this stuff that
they put so much detail into all of this
like the house like none of this is
actually really that relevant to the
game but because they put so much time
and do it it feels yeah it feels like a
real house you know exactly it was like
another vacation it's full of his
memories they're like I can browse
through the photos on his camera like
just things that they definitely didn't
need to include but I think I care if
it's this one or if it's lost legacy
that has the there's a poster that
people thought was a looking Easter Egg
for a last of us to know if it's this
house
ooh double-sink live in his and hers it
just looks like the most like an actual
house and he's been lived in bed not me
because you're just gonna sleep in it
again anyways like I know there's more
stuff to interact with but I'm just
gonna go talk to Elena because I don't
spend too much time I could if I were
streaming the game like when I first
stream the game you know I would just
spend so much time you can like all the
individual things appreciate it all I
was researching something important no
yeah sure thing Thanks spicy dumplings
beers there we go
that's not food but it was like soda or
beer take your pick Oh is he not gonna
grab the food
Oh finish it
yeah you know it's probably too long
let's put beer on the council beverage
you know huh got none of that sorry I'm
sorry how was your day oh it was fine
typical day in paradise yeah I got to
pull a bunch of garbage out of a river
yes
at least you got to go for a swim
optimism fighting garbage Oh brilliant
stuff it was a young early 21st century
truck yeah we got only the natives
called it a semi the boring stuff I tell
me about the article well it started out
as this fluff piece about tourism and
Bangkok but I don't think the magazine
is gonna like the angle that I'm taking
because everyone immediately commented
about how rude the smog was he's gone
yeah well that didn't take long
[Music]
that happened
he's been strolling down memory lane are
you what interesting what's my article
about oh the classic question Oh
flights in Bangkok that our troubles
with them because land Jameson asked you
about that Malaysia job again James and
always asked me about the Malaysian job
look Nate I really think that you should
take it oh dang she's enabling him
rewire he doesn't have the permit we're
not gonna take that kind of work anymore
it doesn't sound that risky alright if
it's just a permit no way you could call
Sullivan you haven't seen him in over
two years
look could we please drop this okay I
just don't want you to not take it
because of me I'm not taking it because
of me okay I appreciate the gesture it's
just
I'm gonna go ahead and do that stop I'll
do no you didn't last now oh you cooked
I cleaned it's fine no if I mean
something let me play it for it oh yeah
your TV game like they beat your high
score I don't need to know what it's
called I've seen you play it's jumping
and running and I have a natural so what
do you say chicken chicken oh yes
completed with with chuckles love it oh
dang boy I love it that's what he was
calling the TV game thing shame on you
yes this is taking a really long time
you have no patience
[Music]
their problem no do you they make it go
push the start button I knew that all
right okay
so you want to run it doesn't deserve
you Elena
crash is also like one of my favorite
series of all time so this is this is
very nice to be eating from the boulders
checkpoint the crash bandicoot series is
a first series I revealed with my mom so
I loved it
perfect
good good another one again yeah you're
on your last life we got this it's our
dessert yeah you can't see what's coming
use your reaction pro-gamer reactions
y'all was that oh my god I didn't make
it to that however Alana's score was
pretty beast she hit every box and got
like everything a lot of the facial
animations are so come on double or
nothing my car could really use it
adorable
they're so cute look at these freakin
goals yeah of course
look away children and now right rated M
for Mature
an exciting life you haven't even
stamping papers we're closed
come on man all right I'm coming coming
yeah can I help you looking for my
little brother the subtitles gave it
away
Ballina nothing less gray in the temples
Sam it's good to see you again next Sam
oh all right all right all right take it
easy
I thought you I saw you get shot yes you
did
every time au well the doctors they
doctors they patched me up and they
tossed me right back into the cell
you've been a me calls I checked
everywhere everything I heard everything
I found it all confirmed you were dead
Nathan we killed the guard okay say they
wanted to see me rot in that cell for
the rest of my life and I nearly did
he's ass am i and if I had known I I
swear to you I would have come on come
back I know it's important now though is
that I'm out
hey hey you still with me no I'm seeing
a ghost right now you're not gonna pass
out on me at night are you
it just might it's a lot to digest you
know but how did you get out when did
you get out
how'd you even get here find me I wrote
it slow down hey have a seat
great Sam is so calm for the situation
here that was a pretty crazy story for
crazy stories
gunshot hanging from a derailed train in
the Himalayas yeah come to my attic I'll
show you oh it's like basically over
do you remember the theory that we had
that Sir Francis Drake faked his own
death sure okay he did I found the
coffin it's a coastal Panama yeah
yeah all right get this okay I open it
up right and there's no body but the
bottom is his old journal you shouldn't
I really like the way they tie the old
games into this one yeah lost city
destroyed and alive barely another lost
city destroyed we do tend to destroy the
things after we find them we should go
to been there it's literally
unbelievable
you tell me you stumble upon yet another
archaeological goldmine and somehow you
managed to walk away with nothing
oh it's the story of my life I guess but
you know I managed to grab a few
trinkets here and there paid off the car
the house engagement ring engagement I'm
married
Elena from the stories that's my wife
you gotta come meet her tonight dinner
at my place you're coming to dinner I
can tell her all about you I'm in a lot
of trouble here what
I'm talking about what kind of trouble
it's an impact alcázar mean about what
you yeah he's the the drug lord boy
butchered up animal matzo it's a really
good funny story but uh last year he was
my cellmate oh so this is how I got out
of prison
[Music]
you're not reading the night Samuel come
here the full name not just Sam what
happens when you're a drug lord no use
everyone's full name gosh they're
singing well they're probably drunk
perhaps but they are content
how can they be contained with your
small lives their miserable jobs
there's no attack I know that one shade
no offense
we have ambition when you get out of
here that ambition I'll take us to
places these idiots cannot even imagine
what will you do when you get out Samuel
that's if I get out of here I'm sure you
can imagine I can but I want to hear you
say it I will find the greatest pirate
treasure of all time which I'm sure you
were sick of hearing about by now oh no
nope the tale of Henry Avery and he's
400 million in jewels and all has become
a sweet lullaby for me do you really
think you can find it given the
opportunity
absolutely ambition what is that Avery
quote I am a man of fortune and I must
seek my fortune I like how he thinks
mm-hmm
was that the opportunity of a lifetime
oh damn second a turkey oh yeah Samos
Cornell Samuel are you ready to seek
your fortune
yo it's kinda epic yeah
feel lucky him to get put in the same
song yeah
we're about to get up out of here by
nerds see you losers and by the way you
guys real quickly today's stream is
sponsored by PlayStation now a service
that lets you stream hundreds of
PlayStation games directly onto your
console and as classic ps2 and ps3 games
all the way up to today's biggest ps4
hits like GTA 5 uncharted 4
and God of War which are available to
play until January 2nd of 2020 you can
also download any ps4 or ps2 games
straight to your ps4 so you can play
them offline at any time and it's as
simple as loading up the game page
within the PlayStation now app and
hitting download that's what we're doing
today for today's stream so hope you
guys are enjoying what you're seeing so
far and thanks for hanging out with us
I'm told us that's blessed us Hector you
do that and we'll start a goddamn riot
exactly
we're escaping from prison man so far so
second time yes second time has to be
the charm so yeah we're loaded this time
and their shot is on point
damn he's a G already he's already been
shot he's already tried to escape once
he's been here for a while I'll have the
ski mask
for me
ah
all right yeah sure oh yeah I see
oh we got a nice little oh so now I got
multiple weapons a spare bulletproof
vest would be really nice
it has more ammo in it so I nee stuff on
him now
[Music]
thank you he's like come on we were
getting choked out
Wow that's how we roll we mouthed off to
those drug lords he needs our help
remember he can't find a treasure like
weekend Oh how big is this prison too
big Oh
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
the music chilled out for a second
must be color again up this I know won't
up the next door oh no our homie who is
blowing up the door is that body
[Music]
I am the treasure hunter guys the
reinforcements
that is correct Robo in the chat mention
there is a 7-day free trial that you can
take advantage of if you want to you
know try out PS now they have so many
games what did they put in the water in
Panama I keep trying to switch to a
better ground they won't let me guys
don't leave me at the squad OH
[Music]
we're just taking down this whole
establishing on line fire my covers
being destroyed yeah
you sinner block though pretty strong
patient ready ok I'll be patient if a
couple more
every other time he's like take cover
Samuel nothing
except
with elastic unmarked white men
easy
oh if I only had some Rockets the first
time we tried to escape wouldn't have
been here for 15 years running off of
adrenaline so what's next for some you
drink Jesus what is next I think a bass
I'm gonna sleep in a real bed I'm gonna
find a nice warm body to sleep next to
me ooh hey check my brother down it
seems like a pretty good start Hades
sorry
how long do you think it will take for
you to retrieve every stretcher I mean
get back to the states I can resume my
search how long no
it's kind of hard to say until I get
started you said you know what IDs yeah
they do
okay but listen it's not like Avery left
some map with a big red X on it okay but
I've got some very star I will turn this
thing around quickly I like you Samuel
more importantly I believed you that is
why you were here I just need some time
let me uncle Gio you see oh I'm having
[Music]
so much six months people are lazy they
always asked for more time than they
actually need three months why'd you ask
me how long I need if you were just
gonna tell me say that was the bait he
was gonna cut it in half no matter how
much time if you run I try to hide the
treasure but does something really
stupid like go to the authorities
I don't know when you least expect it I
will be there at that point if he's not
a mercy I will grant you damn yeah he's
a race that's a very scary line death is
not a mercy I will grant you okay come
on no nearest town ten kilometres in
that direction towards the sunrise
it's been a while since we've seen the
sunrise outside huh give him some money
that's pretty nice it's a fad what I can
yeah
and some water I find it even then what
don't worry when the time comes I'll be
that chocolate oh dang what else work
they sell you
alcázar lets me go and yeah we are
this is bad
just pick up the trail where we left off
wait trail there's no trail after Rafe
and I escaped he took his parents
fortune and bought up all the land
around st. Dismas Cathedral we combed
that place for weeks
Avery's treasure isn't there did that
stop Rafe
Laurens been digging for years still
hasn't turned up squat I'm really
surprised
what's that mean just you know tap them
into little digging of my own and I bet
you Rafe doesn't have this it's really
amazing what you can find on the
Internet these days
it's just the st. Dismas cross because
the one we found was broken in hollow
remember all the crap it's still intact
mmm Avery meat more than one cross so
whatever was missing from the one in
Panama it's probably still inside this
one
all right well where is this oh this
exquisite piece is going up for auction
in three days at the Rossy estate the
Rossi estate oh you know it yeah and how
do you plan on securing an invite
through an exclusive heavily guarded
black market auction don't necessarily
need it yeah and where are you gonna get
the money to up at all the high rollers
I could take a second mortgage out on my
house and it still wouldn't be enough
- you're gonna we are oh no no man
listen I can't I'm out what no I just
don't do that kind of thing anymore
besides there are plenty other guys that
are much more equipped to handle this
kind of thing like who I don't know like
my reason or anybody else see you've got
an F phone with my life okay I need you
on this one
Danny's mom the brother card Oh Sam's
got to be another way
not with the time I got left
yeah how much time elapsed between when
he got out and when he found his brother
cuz that's a big deal - he's like by the
way it took me two and a half months to
find you hey he hunts me ha listen
you're not gonna believe this
Jamison just walked in here with the
permits it's like I'm gonna take that
Malaysia job after all big fat liar and
Elena is so like she knows that yeah I
feel like she would have been down with
it like all right let me pack you a
lunch at honesty is key and no sign from
Sullivan yet there's still plenty of
time
looks like the storage rooms in the
building behind the manor you see from
up there just the very top of it I
wonder what they got tucked away in
there let's just focus on Avery's cross
okay pick up something wife it's cute
it's simple honey stole this from you on
that trip I lied to you romantic it was
just the two of us not cleanly
have you even thought about a back-up
plan in case Sullivan gets cold feet no
because he won't or if he got caught Sam
he knows the people running the auction
he's gonna schmooze his way right
through that party get upstairs unlock
the window and we're in it's a solid
plan mm-hmm
all right fine good say what if he stole
the cross for himself not in a million
he was waiting yes he's double-crossed
people who passed but not us
no not you I know you two have never
seen eye to eye
huge understand but I trust him all
right he's family he's family he's like
I'm your family yeah I'm your brother
fine he'll come through for us it's
always great at least just for one
second consider the posture oh the
signal trust try to keep the tux clean
thanks alright see you into this party
let's do it
the boy Sully coming through in the
clutch
once the thief man that's harsh he got
the via brother card pulled on him you
know third a couple of odd hello Mary
Kay okay well there's that exposed beam
underneath you think you can rope it
that looks like a game mechanic watch
this I'm watching been doing this for 15
years bro oh nothing to do with scripted
while reaching it is safe to jump okay
so this is one of the cool things in
this game where they show like when his
hand goes out and you're like okay now I
can turn how's he supposed to get the
rope
oh yeah insane jump he's gonna make
while you're not looking though you know
just drop down okay I mean with bare
hands
next we can swing off that beam up there
thanks video game
okay can you give me the thing the rope
thing or do I switch places I've got a
good grip okay okay they're weightless
weightless brothers Wow he's like I'm
gonna take the rope but you you can you
can climb over reach the power in these
fingertips though okay I used to do a
lot of bouldering and some of the guys
that I would see just had like just the
biggest hands because their muscle isn't
like all the tiny muscles in your hand
that you don't normally use very often
they have hold onto like grips it's like
that small you know oh my goodness
they're crazy
I mean I watch a lot of like American
Ninja Warrior and they always like have
to make those leaps onto the little
ledge and like it's impossible okay you
could go that way and stop get out of
the way I'm gonna jump over there buddy
you know coming anyways
Oh loaded agreed yeah okay we're good
did you see him was packing some serious
he ran a thug guns Sam we're gonna pull
this off so smoothly we won't need him
right it's like he's still trying to be
a good guy while doing like the bad
stuff and his brothers like it's not
work that should hold
this is a trippy angle rappel down got
it okay swing go further down I did not
pay attention so what the controls are
telling me to do okay I just tried to
launch myself the fingertips oh I'm
gonna go work out my fingertips now so
ever need to do that IRL I won't die
[Music]
once I missed you at least take any
pictures on my flip phone I don't see
this they've like optional kind of we
get back show you you have drawings up
on the fridge or something they're good
drivers come on big brows I've being a
hater Oh live life on the edge can't you
climb up the foliage there by the way
you guys really quickly today's stream
is sponsored by PlayStation now a
service that lets you stream hundreds of
PlayStation games directly onto your
console it has classic ps2 and ps3 games
all the way up to today's biggest ps4
hits like Grand Theft Auto 5 uncharted 4
or God of War which are available to
play until January 2nd 2020 you can also
download any ps4 ps2 game straight to
your ps4 so you can play them offline at
any time it's as simple as loading up
the game page with the within the
PlayStation now app and downloading and
that's what we're doing today
for I'm 34 and there's plenty of other
games if this isn't you know your style
I don't see why it wouldn't be also if
this is you know your first glimpse at
this game all of the previous games in
this series are also available on PSN so
god war is also a super excellent game
that just came out last year but so good
definitely one of my like most favorite
games
oh there there's the window there
what do you think Sam Sam oh there's a
post up there Betty thanks but I don't
miss okay all right Hawkeye we see you
Wow I took the rope with them too
didn't even leave a dangling what
okay you all right yeah how do I look
400 million bucks let's go
know what I love about partying with a
bunch of crooks what's that
nobody cares if you're smoking doors
it's been a while
like he aged twice as much as they
didn't you remember my dead brother
right 15 years yep yeah good to see you
alive Sam
let's try keeping him alive by getting
this cross huh
yeah about that what what about that
come on let me show you something
fancy that's Avery's cross out of
storage just before you guys get here
they changed a lot order take a whole
pile of cash to make that happen
hmm how long before they start the
bidding 10 15 minutes tops that's gotta
be some way we can grab it run overnight
it's just a small matter 100
eyewitnesses the helmet okay but we just
need a diversion like like like I don't
know
but there's got to be something if the
guard see that's making for that cross
they don't see us Jesus you guys act
like you never spend time in prison if
you want something done a new wait for
the lights out yeah that electrical
panel for this place
his ventilation electrical that's it up
here so we just have to climb up there
kill the lights
grab the cross on the dark there will be
an emergency generator then give us a
few seconds of darkness to work with
meaning we'll have to be right next to
the cross when the lights go out there's
no way we can get that close without
being noticed antipasti Mohsen unless
you're servin some hors d'oeuvres ah
standby waiter wouldn't get noticed good
work
that will work all right all right I'll
get to the breaker room
kill the power me now I'm the waiter
you're the best pickpocket all right you
bet down to the floor keep your eye on
the prize okay
let us know if anything that pinky goes
down to that all right listen we still
got this ready ready all right brick go
team yeah I was like wait which role are
we are we climbing are we waiting or
following Sully take us to the promised
land Sully
these other things they're selling just
through there okay let's go
this place is fancy of course they do
oh sorry it's looking at that ice statue
it's locked it's electronic oops act
natural oh my goodness you see that
come on you sure you wanna do that
there's a lot of highs out here I think
I can handle a simple lift all right
oh snap time to pickpocket
[Music]
don't mind me staring at your butt Oh
just zoom in on your butt do you don't
worry about it doink oh he fell upon me
didn't question it though he saw your
face and he's like oh you're good work
hey thanks try this again we'll still
need these great oh snap
we've leveled up the text it's very
mission impossible now look we'll be in
touch
yeah maybe pleasure to see you again
only this time I've got the drop on you
yeah I guess I should recognize you how
do you fatigues yeah you know how it is
every once in a while a job requires us
to get all dolled up looking sharp
by the way not too bad yourself
so out of place she works for like a
private corporation even if you are
American they left the blame my parents
for that chat gone - 18 can I get you
something is in like so many games
recently she's the voice of five so did
sounds like ladies trying to buy you a
drink
Ross doesn't she owned that army for
hire it's called coastline but you had a
run-in with them all right that's and
we're all set Sully stay out of trouble
okay I'll try ready let's do it
and finally the waiters and caterers are
hanging out ler went out of the kitchen
probably dad let's go find the kitchen
yeah I'm hungry let's go find the
kitchen food down here to feed a small
town big houses yeah this is like the
prison with guns the goon squad yeah get
out of here oh that scared me I thought
that was something else
these games are like they're very
cinematic
I see people saying that's like kind of
almost like a movie like these are very
cinematic games which i think is one of
their strong suits one of their many
strong suits what's the I told you it's
locked it's locked
oh you have the Vince Vince that's a
classic way
that's a huge see some fence up there
there we go it's dark okay we're good
let there be light yeah Oh George thank
you don't suppose your brother's nice
Otto hello welcome back what is up run
thank you guys so much for tuning in by
the way been cool checking out some
uncharted 4 with ammunition who's
holding it down for the gameplay today
maze
we're DeWine maze I've played all of the
entire games we have stairs to an I can
talk his way out of anything
hey you ppl yep pressure here what is
that oh here we go yeah why is the
person in the back holding the
flashlight and is mad slow bro you
should be in front with the lighter hey
Vince that's our way out
it's a very hard job Sam has holding the
lady yes he's our only source of light
oh oh okay okay come on I like that it's
like the game does it tell you you need
to go to the vent you know but you can
you look at Sam and you can see that
he's looking up at it yeah you know
right there
Cobra keeper says hey man alcohol is
flammable yeah that's why it's an
important job taking care of that
lighter his wife I know like you good
said you know liquor yeah I think I've
always just assumed it was because it
has some sort of alcohol content in it
I've never thought about it don't try it
at home regardless you guys
no chat do not science
someone else has science did we are very
brotherly which I appreciate that's cute
Sam his name is Troy Baker I can
traverse name from the last of us and
isn't he also in a death stranding I
believe I'm probably he's in a lot of
game so I would see that building with
the radio tower
you mean the cell tower what whatever
listen that's the power room right the
reference because he doesn't know what
doesn't know what that means
that's true Sam I'm up here I'll boost
you up alright good boy
it's nolan north also in deaths training
but there are a lot of people and a lot
of appearances in that games well
honestly I wouldn't Sully you there yo
Oh
Sully's not responding must be a bad
spot for a signal he's doing maybe Nina
wait what did he it wasn't listening to
what he said so I guess we can't go that
way he's looking intently over and over
oh there's another Oh Sam look maybe we
can use that find a window drop into the
kitchen that's a good idea I'll boost
you up and you take care of the ladder
okay sounds like a plan have you ever
tried to boost someone up in real life
like that it's hard feel like never
works that seamlessly suck it in ya
[Music]
wanna set a civilian Sam right okay
let's get to the power room
Sam you good right skinny jeans I'm not
really sure I feel like it looks like
you can climb that but I don't know how
to get there from there
yeah and I'm scared to jump because it
looks really far yeah that looks way too
far right so almost everything looks
like a climb above ledge to me in this
games I'm constantly just like running
into the wall like maybe oh oh yeah yeah
we're making a wave going somewhere
climbin I love even if you just like
move the thumbstick very slightly he
moves his hand kind of in like during
yeah needs to go like those small
animations are so good in this game
makes you really feel like you have
control over the character yeah makes it
seem more real - because they're not
just like snapping their movements from
one place to another you know the Lost
Legacy standalone game that they made
that featured Chloe and Nadine actually
was oh there are a lot of like really
cool fight animations that they had but
it just makes the game feel so real so
like Naughty Dog is so good at those
things
gotta applaud this upper-body strength
though it's remarkable he stayed in good
shape for not doing this kind of stuff
but maybe his job still has a lot of
that guy's you can hear me just about at
the power room are we Canyon
so I'm almost there guys I'll be there
in five minutes
three hours later like are you sure okay
I don't think we can go that way mmm do
you like we want to get across that roof
can I jump
that looks jumpable yeah that forum oh
man he like caught that with his face
okay what it's right there you silly
unfortunately guys we will not be doing
a full playthrough our time here on
stream is almost done but we're gonna
make it to this power room all right why
is he so happy to be this lighting to
his death thought that was taken away
for a month and what about the horse
fortunately we had a lot of carrots
recognize someone I thought I did
what am I finally going to meet that
partner of yours dreck that's ex-partner
I've been flying solo for a while now
Drake's out well then he might as well
be dead right Oh Victor Sullivan hard
hello how long has it been ten years
twelve fifteen it's amazing all these
years gone by here we are we're still
haggling over dead people's junk really
aren't you running your parents business
my business now but yes that is my deal
probably afford to buy up everything on
the block tonight well sure what would
be the point in that these days I'm only
looking for that
good stuff big scores any advice on what
I should pick up tonight yeah
like I want a bid against him but just
between you and me I didn't notice they
change the order I think somebody might
be trying to rig this option yeah 100%
the guy with all the money which is what
you really need someone with an inlaid
wooden crucifix from the trophy state
well I know when I'm a third wheel you
two kids have fun a nice hold on sorry
no don't touch me
word are you sorry overstepping the line
what it is that riff Nadine I think your
partner has had too many Bloody Mary
you're causing a scene but if you think
about bidding on Avery's cross I can
tell you exactly
and God right
you get my point
lovely seeing you both slowly knock this
man out one time dress me and while
we're still hanging off a cliff a minute
he's so dirty he's never gonna be both
so able to blend in now oh good okay
we'll stop swinging you're just the grip
and the iron grip uh no this is
definitely not a first-person shooter
it's more like like a linear
storytelling game but then there's
elements that are like cover shooter
kind of when you actually do have a gun
there's lots of like shooting at people
from cover we take those other way they
tricked me they put some climb of all
things on that side oh yeah
I don't like the way that barbed and
yeah things have a tendency to break in
Nathan Drake's world quite often so if
you've played the previous games I don't
trust anything anymore because
everything he touches just gets
destroyed
all right oh we got some some rintah
thugs are you doing okay real quiet now
so she's so loud there's no way you
would hear somebody like you wouldn't
hear somebody stepping we need to go in
there somehow oh I just a circle okay
how do I get down from here
[Music]
come on me we gotta go man people are
waiting for us unlocked right you can
squeeze through those bars slowly we're
stealing remember
we have 90,000 do I hear any more of you
I end up with the highest bid we're all
dead Emily I need you to buy me more
time literally trust me
immediately all the slow raise
yes bleed them dry Sully we can pay okay
we're not buying it we're stealing it
okay we gotta smash the lock whoa
130,000 go faster neat fine I know these
babies going one of these is fine due to
something Oh the trusty crowbar boys we
already know when name you're going get
it Solis pour monies which you ready
thank you
[Music]
me worried there for a minute
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
no I don't all right you guys well we
are gonna have to wrap it up here
unfortunately because it's really
getting juicy it really is but that is
all of our time today unfortunately that
is gonna wrap up today's stream which
was sponsored by PlayStation now and
with PlayStation now you can stream
hundreds of ps4 ps3 and PS to games
directly to your console or PC with new
games being added every month in
addition you can download any ps4 game
in the service on to your console to
play it anytime
so with hits like fallout 4 NBA 2k 18
Mortal Kombat X and rocket League you're
gonna have a lot of stuff to play you
can learn more about that at PS now.com
so don't miss your opportunity to play
hundreds and hundreds of games for a
very low price streaming to your console
don't worry about space or play it on PC
it's good times all around thank you
again so much and for playing some
uncharted with us today and it was a
really really fun time wish we could
have played more but that's all for our
time today hope you guys enjoyed the
show and please come on back we are
extreme II every day here for a GameSpot
live at 11:00 a.m. Pacific time on
weekdays so we'd love to see you guys
again soon
but until next time peace out